[Music]
hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to mkb hd
update 5.0 yeah it does seem like a lot
of updates uh but actually in my one
year or so on youtube it does seem like
a realistic amount for me so basically
this is a testing sort of video for me
and also for the audience to see your
guys uh your responses the first thing
i'm testing is the quality of this new
sanyo zak d cg 10 camcorder obviously
i've done a few macro focus tests as
well as this which is a slightly more
distant shot with decent lighting so it
looks good
the second test is uh for this new
camera angle you can see my monitors
behind me
you can see a little bit more of what i
look like when i'm sitting in my office
not a whole lot but it's a little bit
better quality obviously than me sitting
in front of my webcam uh built into my
pc
and this is also going to be a test for
two more things one is the transition
you're about to see between this video
and the screencast that i'm going to go
into and the last and probably the most
important part of this update video is
that every machine in this home office
is now running windows 7 home premium so
you guys are going to get the best of
the best quality most likely in 1080p
video uh this is going to be a pretty
big change in my videos but not the most
uh in terms of what it's going to be
about but in terms of quality so you
guys are going to get the highest
quality professional video that i can
possibly output uh several times a week
due to this upgrade to windows 7.
so i'm going to test out this transition
pretty quickly and we're going to switch
into our screencast
and we're going to just demonstrate a
quick piece of software i'm not quite
sure what i'm going to do yet but it
should be fun so uh welcome to this new
transition this new angle this new sort
of video setup and let's just get right
into this
[Music]
so here it is guys this is the quality
test of the screencast with windows 7
home premium everything is pretty much a
clean install i have yet to import my
settings and documents for my external
hard drive but this is what it looks
like so i've i've obviously downloaded
and installed camtasia studio 6 as well
as a number of other programs just to
get me started and help me know you know
what's really on my computer and get
things going so i have a nice little
carbon fiber background going on here
things are very very snappy extremely
fast on windows 7 uh in comparison to
windows vista so uh yeah that is
basically it for mkbhd update 5.0 if you
would like more information about this
camcorder you can go back to the
unboxing video that i did and the
quality test that i did and if you want
more information about windows 7 i'll
leave you guys some sort of link in the
description to check it out so anyway
thanks for watching mkbhd update 5.0
it's been a pleasure and i hope you guys
continue to watch my videos in the
future so thanks for watching mkbhd
signing out peace